[Music]
[Applause]
good morning John it's Wednesday January
17th hi Maureen Johnson and E Lockhart
Maureen is that the Maureen that told me
to build a business card house out of my
misprinted business cards if it is then
I have a surprise for her last night I
spent two hours talking to a libertarian
on the Internet
it was a friend of mine from high school
and I don't know what happened he says
there shouldn't be regulations on
nuclear power plants last night I also
blew my nose for 15 straight minutes and
then at the end of it I had converted 6
ounces of toilet paper into two pounds
of mushy goo but now I can do this
I'm just gonna jump right into
misprinted business card utilization
ideas marine from the comments suggested
that I build a business card house I
didn't know how to build card houses so
I went on the internet and did some
research there's the basic card house
where you use you know this and this and
then you stack until it gets high up but
that's not the best way to build card
houses it turns out I found out the way
that the professional card stackers do
it and now I'm going to teach you and
all of our viewers how to stack cards
the awesome way we created T and we
leaned this card on this card thus
stabilizing this card and this card is
that guy weren't jammie pants this guy
on this guy yes that guy is wearing
jammie pants it's early and I'm sick and
tired ok I mean this guy I'm not God I
mean this guy
okay
here we've got the first story of a
really good card house and now we add
the roof and this is important because
we're going to be stacking more stories
on it
and
oh there we have the first story of a
card house
let us take a look at this thing of
beauty
an excellent misprinted business car
utilization idea especially because now
I know how to stack hearts and hopefully
so do you so I can't just let this go
I'm gonna have to try and add another
story